the the the debate you did with bill nye
was seven years ago yeah it was not bill
i was on well it did three meetings
one was on your own so one was on piers
and oregon and one was and how often do
you do do you do debates like that great
question you used to do them all the
time i mean all the time i mean in the
from 2000 to
2016 it was regular debating donald
trump won the media said we could never
allow someone like him to win again we
can no longer allow dissent and they
just stopped it all but i was doing that
regularly abc news uh cnn regularly on
seeing a don lemon show they would have
me we were all but then it just they
decided that
scott pelley cbs news anchor then cbs
news anchor said i will not interview a
climate denier for the same reason i
won't interview a holocaust denier well
when's the last time that you did a
debate
well with the guy at the heritage but
the only debates they allow now are with
other republicans who believe climate's
a problem what free market solutions no
that i'm trying to think that's a
problem because
they're silencing yes they have the
outlier debate was dan bongino
had wanted me to debate the un report
last summer in august of 2021 they
couldn't find anyone they ended up
getting some surrogate biden spokesman
who didn't really know anything about
the climate he just read a couple
talking points but beyond that it's been
years because they will and there's no
it's not just me but no one's allowed to
debate it's very very very rare so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]